USABLE MUSICAL >> Greg:
BREAKING NEWS REGARDING
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN, SOME OF
THIS INFORMATION MAY BE SHOCKING
IF YOU HAVE ANY CHILDREN IN THE
ROOM YOU MAY WANT THEM TO LEAVE,
I WILL GIVE YOU THREE SECONDS.
WE’VE JUST LEARNED FROM OUR
HARDWORKING COLLEAGUES AT CNN
THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS
EXPRESSED A PREFERENCE FOR
BUILDING A FIRE IN THE
OVAL OFFICE AND SOMETIMES HE HAS
A LOG TO KEEP IT GOING.
LET’S GO ON THE GROUND TO ONE OF
OUR REPORTERS.
>> THANKS, GREG, I’M OUTSIDE
WALKING, HOLDING A NOTEPAD AND
IT’S TRUE, PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS
EXPRESSED A PREFERENCE FOR A
FIRE BUILT IN THE OVAL OFFICE
AND SOMETIMES HE WILL ADD A LOG
TO KEEP IT GOING.
ACCORDING TO MY SOURCES, THIS IS
QUITE A DEPARTURE FROM THE
PREVIOUS TENANT OF THE
WHITE HOUSE, WHOSE ONLY FIRES HE
STOKED WHERE THAT OF HATRED AND
BIGOTRY.
OF COURSE THAT CAME FROM AN
ANONYMOUS SOURCE WHO MIGHT ALSO
BE ME.
BACK TO YOU, GREG.
>> Greg: THIS INFORMATION
COMING FROM CNN, LIKELY THROUGH
AN ANONYMOUS SOURCE BUT WE HAVE
NO REASON TO QUESTION IT.
LET’S BRING ONE OF OUR EXPERTS
ON THIS.
GREG, WHAT YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> THANKS, GREG.
AS A HISTORIAN, FROM A
HISTORICAL PERSPECTIVE THIS IS
QUITE ASTOUNDING.
GEORGE WASHINGTON CHOPPED DOWN
THE CHERRY TREE BUT HE WASN’T
RESOURCEFUL ENOUGH TO USE IT AS
FUEL.
UNLIKE PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN,
AGAIN AS A HISTORIAN I DON’T
THINK IT’S PREMATURE TO SAY WE
ARE WITNESSING THAT THE GREATEST
PRESIDENT WE’VE EVER SEEN.
THE GREATEST PRESIDENT WE WILL
EVER SEE.
SORRY, GREG, WE ARE GETTING MORE
BREAKING NEWS FROM CNN.
IT APPEARS THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
SPENT THAT TIME READING THE
NEWSPAPER.
CNN DESCRIBES HIM AS "A WARY
PASSENGER ON A COMMUTER
SHUTTLE."
LET’S GO BACK TO OUR EXPERT FOR
A QUICK REACTION.
>> IS A PROMINENT HISTORIAN I
CAN SEE THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN’S
METHOD OF RELAXATION CALLED TO
MIND THE GREAT LEADERS OF OUR
TIME.
WHAT A ROLE MODEL FOR CHILDREN
WHOSE PARENTS HAVE PRIVATE JETS.
IT’S SO IMPORTANT TO READ WHEN
YOU CAN EVEN AT 35,000 FEET.
GREG, EVEN AT 35,000 FEET.
A LOT GOING ON ON THIS VERY BUSY
DAY AT THE CAPITAL, AP REPORTING
THE PRESIDENT OF EACH ONE OF HIS
GRANDDAUGHTERS IS AT A VIDEO GAM
KNOWN AS "MARIO KART."
I’M SORRY, WE DON’T CONDONE MEN
BEATING WOMEN AT ANYTHING AND I
WILL BE TAKING A LEAVE OF
ABSENCE TO PROFOUNDLY EDUCATE
MYSELF ON THIS MATTER.
I ALWAYS WANTED TO INTERVIEW
MYSELF.
>> Dana: VERY GOOD.
>> Greg: THANK YOU, DANA, THIS
IS SOME HARD-HITTING STUFF FROM
CNN.
>> Dana: IT MUST BE FUN TO BE
A DEMOCRATIC P.R. PERSON.
OR MAYBE IT’S BORING BECAUSE
IT’S LIKE SO EASY.
ACTUALLY I THINK EVERY PRESIDENT
HAS A FIRE IN THE OVAL OFFICE.
I’M PRETTY SURE.
THEY BETTER ENJOY IT WHILE THEY
CAN, I THINK THE RUBBER IS GOING
TO HIT THE ROAD PRETTY SOON, I
THINK THAT THE SORT OF
UNDERSTANDING AND TRUCE BETWEEN
THE PROGRESSIVES AND MODERATE
DEMOCRATS IS GOING TO COME
CRASHING TO AN END.
>> Greg: KENNEDY, I STILL
DON’T KNOW WHETHER HE HAS
WHIPPED CREAM ON HIS
HOT CHOCOLATE.
>> Kennedy: AND MARSHMALLOWS,
GREG, I HOPE THE ADMINISTRATION
TAKES A FIRM STANCE HERE BECAUSE
THESE ARE THE IMPORTANT TOPICS.
I’M WATCHING THIS AND THINKING
IT REMINDS ME OF GOING TO JAPAN
IN THE MOUNTAINS AND SEEING THE
LITTLE SNOW MONKEYS, WHO ARE
ADORABLE AND EVERYONE WALKS
AROUND GOING ON MY GOSH, THESE
MONKEYS ARE ADORABLE.
THEY THROW SNOWBALLS AND THEN
STEAL YOUR STUFF.
IMAGINE THE KIND OF DAMAGE AND
ADORABLE PRESIDENT CAN DO WHEN
THE PRESS ISN’T WATCHING, WHEN
THEY ARE SO BUSY FAWNING AND
GIVING EVERY NUANCE OF HIS
ADORABLE LIFE, HE’S GOING TO BE
PILFERING AND ROBBING THE
COUNTRY BLIND AND I’M SORRY TO
SAY, GREG, AS A REALIST, WE ARE
ALL HOSED.
>> Greg: THIS HAS TO BE THE
EASIEST WHITE HOUSE BEAT IN
HISTORY.
>> Juan: ACTUALLY, I’M GLAD
YOU PUT IT THAT WAY, GREG,
BECAUSE HISTORICALLY THIS IS
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU GET A NEW
PRESIDENT, THEY START TALKING,
DOES HE LIKE NESTLE
HOT CHOCOLATE OR OVALTINE, WHAT
ARE HIS FAVORITE BOOKS, WHAT
ABOUT THE DOGS?
THIS IS THE WAY THAT THE PRESS
DOES IT.
OF COURSE THE HISTORICAL CYCLE
HOLDS THAT OF COURSE THE NEXT
STEP IS THEY BRING OUT THE
BASEBALL BATS AND BEGIN
WALLOPING HIM.
BUT I THINK THAT WHAT WE ARE
DOING HERE IS TALKING ABOUT,
THEY DIDN’T DO THIS SO MUCH WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP BUT YOU GOT TO
REMEMBER THE FIRST TIME OUT OF
THE BOX, TRUMP WAS LYING ABOUT
THE SIZE OF THE INAUGURAL CROWD,
HE HAD THE BAN ON PEOPLE OF
MUSLIM FAITH COMING INTO THE
COUNTRY SO I THINK A LOT OF
THINGS JUST GOT SKIPPED.
I THINK THE BAN IS A FACT, I
DON’T KNOW HOW YOU ARGUE THAT.
IT JUST GOT SKIPPED AND OF
COURSE LOTS OF ANGER AND THE
MEDIA GOING AFTER HIM.
I THINK WHAT ARE THE THINGS THAT
BIDEN IS SELLING HIS NORMALCY,
THAT THINGS CAN BE NORMAL AGAIN
AND RIGHT NOW THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE IN THE PRESS ARE BUYING
IT.
>> Greg: THE VARIABLE IN THE
BAND COUNTRY IS "MUSLIM" BECAUSE
THERE WERE MUSLIM COUNTRIES THAT
WEREN’T BANNED.
JESSE, ARE YOU EXCITED ABOUT THE
TOWN HALL TONIGHT ON ANOTHER
NETWORK, WILL YOU BE WATCHING
IT?
SPEECH YOU KNOW, I WON’T, I’M
GOING TO BE WATCHING
"THE BACHELOR" RERUN BECAUSE I
MISSED IT LAST NIGHT.
WE JUST GOT OFF THREE YEARS OF A
ROLLER COASTER AND NOW WE ARE
WRITING THE TEA CUPS AND THE
PRESS IS TRYING TO SELL THIS AS
SOMEHOW SEXY, THE INANE DETAILS
OF JOE BIDEN’S PERSONAL
LIFESTYLE.
I DON’T CARE HOW MANY LOGS HE
PUTS ON THE FIRE OR WHAT TIME HE
GOES TO BED.
WE JUST HAD ENTERTAINMENT
TONIGHT IN THE WHITE HOUSE, DIES
ORDERING McDONALD’S AND
ATTACKING PEOPLE ON TWITTER PAST
MIDNIGHT, ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
YOU CAN’T NOW GO TO THIS AND
SAY, YEAH, HE BEATS HIS
GRANDDAUGHTER AT "MARIO KART"
AND EXPECTS US TO READ THIS.
THE REAL ACTION, THOUGH, THE
FAMILY SCANDAL IN THE RADICAL
POLICY.
IF YOU HAVE A PRESIDENT WHOSE
SON AND BROTHER ARE UNDER
INVESTIGATION FOR A CHINESE
MONEY LAUNDERING AND TAX FRAUD.
YOU ARE SENDING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO CORRUPT TEACHERS
UNIONS WITH A HISTORY OF
EMBEZZLEMENT.
HE’S JUST SPIKING THE CUOMO
NURSING HOME INVESTIGATION,
THAT’S WHERE THE ACTION IS, NOT
THE BEDTIME AND THE LOGS.
>> Greg: THAT IS EXACTLY
KENNEDY’S POINT, THAT HE IS
GETTING AWAY WITH STUFF BECAUSE
HE’S JUST SO -- TO JUAN’S POINT,
TO YOUR POINT, TRUMP WAS SO
OVER-THE-TOP THAT HE COULDN’T
GET AWAY WITH ANYTHING BECAUSE
THEY WERE WATCHING HIS EVERY
SINGLE MOVE BECAUSE EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF HIS MOVES WAS INTERESTING
AND OVER-THE-TOP SO THEY WATCHED